- [Narrator] With a head of
hair that can literally stun,
this is the curly hair tarantula.
(gentle music)
The unusual hairs on the
curly hair tarantula are
both its most distinguishing
feature and its best weapon.
When threatened, it will
kick hairs off its abdomen
that blind looming predators.
Found throughout Central
America, this burrowing species
is found in scrubland.
Nocturnal by nature, the
curly hair tarantula is an
opportunistic hunter, ready
to eat whatever passes by.
This spider has extremely
poor eyesight, but at the end
of its legs are receptors
that are sensitive to smell,
taste and vibration.
Once the tarantula detects
its prey, it injects
paralyzing venom through
two hollowed fangs.
Despite their popularity
in the insect pet trade,
wild curly hair tarantulas
are at risk due to habitat
loss in Central America.
This is the curly hair tarantula.
(gentle music)